um
as a producer i know
sometimes you'll take like uh loops from
other up-and-coming producers or certain
[ __ ] like how's your process in terms of
like
do you still
like look for loops or [ __ ] like that
from like i really look for loose no
more i kind of just shine the kids who
got five loops now cause i just we used
to go through too much [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] like
like we'll take a kid that was nobody
and blow them up and make them something
and then
they start want to charge us like they
us like you know it's like you won't get
a placement if i don't use your loot
yeah it's like this now you're gonna do
this same [ __ ] with the same loop and
send it to the future and see we see if
we even play it see if he even can get
it to him
like you know what i'm saying so what i
started doing is i signed him first i
didn't sign probably over
40 kids in the last two years 40
producers so you have your team of
producers and then from there everyone
just kind of contributes and then you
put your sauce on it or
do or sometimes will you make a beat and
then send it to your guys to see if they
can add to it i'll make beats with my
guys you don't do that no no like i let
them do them if they make a beat they go
up you made it yeah
you know some i mean listen some of your
counterparts are not the same
yeah for sure because some of your
counterparts i agree will just take a
beat from some little homie they signed
and just throw their tag on i agree you
know what i'm saying i don't really do
that it's not really my thing like you
know unless i'm trying to take a kid
that nobody knows completely but i'm
still gonna put his tag in here i'm
still gonna post him
like you know i'm saying like if i'm
trying to take him from zero to fifteen
thousand dollars would be in six months
then i'm gonna do some [ __ ] like that
that's the only way like you feel me but
i'm still gonna give him all the credit
because i need him to be
i need like my dream is to have a a pub
company for the celebrity producers
mm-hmm that's what it was i mean i'm
about to say you pretty much kind of
i'm almost there yeah
for you like because i do feel like
being a producer is kind of like um
it feels like such a saturated field to
try to get involved in and i [ __ ]
know we made it fun now man mitchell was
talking about this but i was gonna say
like if you're a up and coming producer
how do you get like some people will do
the tight beats on youtube some people
will go on beat stars and sell lease
beats like if you're nobody stars i
don't know why if you're a nobody i
really hate b stars you know why i hate
b stars because
they like these stars selling these kids
right
so i know a kid that sold a beat on b
stars
actually
and lost all everything for a thousand
bucks it was a murray record too
for a thousand bucks like you know what
i'm saying like that [ __ ] cool at the
time but it's like
i was raised my mom my dad taught me if
he was ignorant that's not my fault
yeah you're saying the paperwork yeah i
like you s b star that's what you did
with b star so if you put this beat up
for self with me on b stars i'm gonna
put my card on b stars i'm gonna buy it
yeah and buy all your rights for a
thousand dollars it's like you know i'm
still gonna leave you as the producer
but yeah you're gonna get your pub or do
you even get the pub they don't get no
pub that's what i'm saying oh [ __ ] you
just thousand dollars i just bought you
a pub and it's a full buyout i just keep
your name on it right
yeah i don't really like that like you
know i feel like they should at least
get them kids let them keep half of it
or you know something i don't know what
would be um advice though you'd give to
up-and-coming producers just in terms of
like getting attention or getting just
like what avenue should they go through
to try to get
um you know kids what i noticed about a
lot of these kids like these kids like
to skip the step of the step of things
that like me metro lex luger sunny
digital like
mike will like they like to skip those
steps and things that we went through
which steps
they're struggling you know having to go
to sessions and just wait outside i hope
i can get in and play beats like
like [ __ ] like that like you know what
i'm saying like
and and of course i make it where these
kids can't skip steps but
it's like don't take this [ __ ] for
granted you know what i'm saying it's
like a lot of late nights in the studio
and then even if someone cuts to your
record it might not ever [ __ ] come
out right now i was in the studio with
her it's 7 00 am 8 am this morning
i ain't bad i'm going off like four
hours of sleep